hello welcome back to hey [ __ ] we are
the [ __ ] and hey hey people like that
you brought up votes so we're the green
aback yeah we are the [ __ ] and hey oh
I like it I miss her yeah I wish she was
here right now yeah I really wish she
was here right now yeah miss Bose I hope
you're watching this but who is here
let's take let's take a roll call um
[ __ ] gio i'm [ __ ] nikki you don't have
to call yourself a [ __ ] Cassie I'm
Jessica just know you're one and I'm
Cassie welcome to the show today
Cassie's thank you so much for being
here thanks for having me for those of
you who don't know she's Blogilates on
YouTube and pretty much everywhere right
that's yeah i'm randy is on point lucky
I got in early yeah that's a good name
she's literally everywhere you can find
her at like 24-hour fitness you can find
her like you were at like in Jamba Juice
like you're literally everywhere yeah
she works her fitness courses at 24 hour
fitness I think she like she came up
with her own stuff like that's not bad
as she is
Cassie is in the health and fitness
industry and how did that come to be
like how did you start that okay so when
I was 16 I got super into Pilates I
started doing Pilates DVDs Mari Winsor I
don't know if anyone remembers that
mercial yes huge huge so I got super
into it and I started doing her like
DVDs in my bedroom and it's so funny
because now girls are doing my youtube
videos in their bedrooms I've done your
YouTube videos a lot yeah that one was
like my go-to oh that's a good one yeah
that's when I memorized all the words
yeah basically yourself right so when I
got into college I needed like a side
job so I went on Craigslist and I found
that they were looking for a Pilates
instructor down the street and I totally
wasn't even certified but I was like
whatevs I'm gonna go to the audition
anyway
so I went and then they really liked me
found out I wasn't certified so they're
like okay we'll like fund your
certification so I started teaching in
college and that's how it started then
in 2009 I filmed my first youtube video
not thinking it beat anything it was
literally me filming my final like
workout for my classes in Southern
California before I moved off to Boston
for my first job it was a 10-minute ab
workout for like literally 40 people at
24-hour fitness so I started working at
24 hour fitness too so basically it was
for 40 people and then the next time I
looked at it there are a few hundred
views and then thousands of views and
people asking for more so that's half
2009 is like og Oh super like super I
don't even think that beauty gurus
though a term that they used today to
refer to like that group wasn't even a
thing yet yeah I think it was just
Michelle Phan yeah yeah andreaschoice
like they're twins yeah yeah but but it
wasn't like a big thing it wasn't like
Oh beauty gurus like it was just
starting yeah and also like back then
because I was a certified instructor but
I was on YouTube like the traditional
media was like oh you're not legit whole
it was like that whereas now they're
like oh social media people like it
let's write all about that we're all
celebrities we all have to start a
social media oh my god so many people
that because I was from like acting and
I and my manager at the time was like
just gonna ruin your career and all
kinds of my god and now every actor
wants the social media so you got in on
the ground floor really early and so
you've always kind of shared your
journey right with everybody that's
following along I think that's really
inspirational and I've definitely been
helped by your videos before but
recently you were sharing about your
newest goal and you got some flack for
it
yeah time for the tea kettle isn't ruing
okay so like do you guys ever feel like
the more you're on social media the
bigger you get the more like people
criticize you but literally
yeah okay absolutely so like back when I
started in oh nine and stuff I was
blogging that's how Blogilates can be
I'm a blogger and I do Pilates anyway so
I would just like write whatever I
thought and literally guys my stuff
isn't even offensive it's like I'm like
Disneyland like I really I mean there's
nothing about ready right so anyway as
social media became more of a thing
everything that I said or did became
criticized so then I was like oh like I
don't want to offend anyone so I started
like closing in and not like saying
things anymore and I just felt like a
vanilla cupcake who had to be perfect at
all times
yeah and then you know a few weeks ago I
went to a retreat and had this epiphany
that I am no longer being myself
I'm not even authentic to myself because
I'm scared of hurting people's feelings
and again I'm not even doing offensive
things so it's like you know what I want
to get in the best shape of my life
mentally and physically so I'm gonna
blog every single day because I had use
I used to blog seven days a week back in
the day and then as people start saying
more more stuff I went down to literally
seven times a year
Wow yeah oh my and writing is my therapy
and so I just been feeling really like
just not myself so I was looking up
we're gonna do this 90 days twelve weeks
is amount of time it takes usually for a
transformation if you're super focused
and so I announced that I announced that
I wanted to have get down to athlete
body fat percentage level and I also
said this probably means that I'll get
to a certain weight and as soon as I
announced that and what I was gonna do
how is gonna eat people like flipped out
and they're like oh my god you're such a
disappointment and embarrassment to our
community you're a bad role model for
women everywhere
unfollow unsubscribe but when you're
seeing crazy these are literally you're
fat my pants so what did you say
anything to like shame people that
weren't doing it or anything so okay so
this is my theory on how this all
happened okay so very realistically like
when I look at my body and you compare
me to you know your traditional like
trainer or like Fitness person they've
got a six six pack abs they've got huge
butts and they just look away yeah I
don't look that way okay like I'm just
very I don't know quote-unquote normal
or something and the media once you
start talking about me years ago they
kind of categorized me into the
body-positive group because I didn't
love so
like for me it's like I never set out to
be a body-positive activist I was just
me being me teaching Pilates because at
the end of the day I'm a group fitness
instructor I teach I make sure that you
guys can help find the joy in working
out that is my mission and my purpose
but then the media put me in that body
positive group which is fine like I
think that's great and I think the whole
body positive movement is so wonderful
because as we see more more women post
pictures in the cells but yeah I'm you
know rolls or cellulite like it's really
impounded of lines literally with what
you just said yes it's a mental state of
mind it is totally mental city mine so
anyway I think the body positive
movement is great but because it got
categorized in that space as an activist
all of a sudden now me wanting to lose
some weight it's like a problem is it
shouldn't body pause it but body
positivity be about like you know
whatever you want your body to be like
you get to celebrate that yeah not like
don't have any goals can never do never
never
yeah well it's like you can never have
any muscle definition because now you're
you're written on yourself outside of
the normals the normal bubble so that's
just so odd it's almost like you're like
into organic food or whatever and then
you want to try a cool like makeup look
that's like not a natural makeup look
people are like what the [ __ ] yeah get
out like literally literally no I
hundred percent like I am still you know
the reason why I started this journey
was for myself so I have to keep
reminding myself don't worry what they
about what they say yes but it's just
like it's crazy how people can twist the
word body positivity and use it how they
want to use it I think there's a lot of
things that get confused there's body
positivity there's fat acceptance
there's the whole origin of body
positive with Kate which came from like
someone recovering from anorexia but at
the end of the day I feel that if I'm
being positive about my body during my
journey no matter if I want to gain
weight lose weight or literally whatever
that's my whole thing but for someone
else to go out and say like Oh Cassie
has an eating disorder she is relapsing
she has a mental health illness that she
needs to see a professional and it's
just like really offensive because it's
like you don't even know me
like I have goals and just because I
decided to announce my numerical goals
does not mean I have a problem it means
I am focused and that's how I function
in my business in my everyday life I am
numbers focus I like analytics yeah my
theory is that people are bored and
there's like a severe lack of identity
right now and people are latching on to
like oh well I don't want to you know
like I'm gonna be body-positive or
whatever and that means this and they
define it so strictly and then they just
project anyone that's not doing that
thing you know in a composite body
positivity it could be in politics it
could be a environmentalist it could be
the UV gun or whatever whatever it is if
you're not following the rules and
structure and there being a perfect body
positive person and you're not and
you're going outside the box they just
like need to put you down in order to
build their identity up yes I confirm
that they're doing the right ball and
you're all Siculus I mean they found
like their little safe space and like
you're challenging that for them so
you're making them focus on themselves
and they don't like that because you're
like they're like well positive body
positivity to me sounds like I can click
corners I can be a little bit lazy
basically doing what I'm doing right now
but now Cassie's the person that I was
latching on to now she has goals and I'm
like I don't and like I don't like that
about myself so I'm gonna put her down
literally what you said yeah like I i
100% understand why this is happening I
knew I was gonna get controversy by
announcing that had numerical goals and
one of the main comments that I kept
getting was oh my gosh Cassie like your
goal weight or no no your starting
weight is my goal weight and like you
already look good you have no fat to
lose it's like you don't even like know
what like oh yeah Fitness Instructor and
I I like Fitness and like go hard so I
understand that because my whole mission
is find the join working out make making
sure it's fun I normally don't talk
about that stuff but I wasn't a bikini
competition back in 2012 where like
numbers were super in yeah Lisa I
understand that kind of training but I
think a lot of people start following me
after that yeah they don't know that
world they don't know that world so that
all of a sudden Fitness you have to
understand and you have to understand
that it's just a number it's not
something emotional so I
a lot of people came on like seeing me
as like the spotty positive role model
we'll just wonderful because I truly
believe you find the joy in working out
the numbers really are just a side
benefit yeah but there's a season for
everything in this season I'm focusing
on the numbers because I want to get to
a certain place yeah I think that's fine
you know it'd be really dope I feel like
because this is a journey for you right
and you want to bring along your loyal
fans I think it would be really cool to
educate them on that because if me I
have a business of a fitness background
so I understand when you say numbers and
then BMI and all that stuff I get what
you're talking about and and I know it's
goal driven and I know that like there's
different body fat percentages that will
make people look like if there's someone
that's a bodybuilder well you know those
really jacked me yeah they're dudes for
some people that's disgusting and
they're like whoa like that guys
obviously on Ron you know roids and yuck
like that's not even human but for other
people it's like wow that's dedication
hard work right but if you don't come
from that space that's why when girls
are lifting the majority of people are
like people too are like well she
shouldn't be lifting she's gonna look
muscular and big like those those
bodybuilder guys so it'd be cool if you
take your fans on that journey of like
hey let me introduce you to the whole
scope of this Fitness world this is what
a bodybuilders look like this is this is
what they do this is a crossfitter this
is whatever and like you you're kind of
educating them and kind of giving them
like a crash course yeah
yeah that's why I'm writing about
everything on my blog every day are you
writing about the adversity - that's
literally the first like five days was I
don't want it to sound like I was
defending myself but I felt like it was
me defending myself yeah I just want
again like this is why me I just like
want to do what I do but it's like I
have to keep explaining why I'm telling
you my number is because if someone is
joining in right now they're like whoa
like she's crazy or she's obsessive but
you know what do you think it's a bad
thing to lose those people because that
means you're outgrowing each other you
guys just don't understand in each other
anymore you know I might if if my
content isn't serving you it's cool like
break up with me you don't need to be
here I want to be someone who can guide
you and give you what you need in life
to achieve what you want to achieve and
if
these 90 days don't serve you then it's
cool I think it's good that they leave
if they know that they're in their head
this mental space is not safe for them
they should go and I think it's fine I
think it's absolutely fine yeah I would
agree that with with that and on that
note we're gonna take our first break we
will be right back
well it's not really a break you're
still gonna see us actually so right
here first sponsor today is Lola thank
you to Lola and this is cool because
they deal with not being awkward they
deal with not being offered yeah I don't
understand what you're trying to tell me
right now okay all right you'll see Lola
is a female founded company offering a
line of organic tampons pads liners
all-natural cleansing wipes oh they
actually have cleansing wipes no did we
have it last time
I think you're gonna turn that back to
my awkward I'm like no I'm not Steve so
you don't have to feel awkward
no the awkward part is that they deliver
so you can do all of the shopping online
it's sorry you don't so bye Stephanie
yes so for me growing up that was I
dreaded having a go to the grocery store
just because I needed pads and I'm like
oh my god people are gonna know that I'm
free completing Reina oh it was so
freaking embarrassing so I would buy
another item that would cover it like a
box of cereal and something that it
never actually hides it you're like a
boy I am but it's just cuz I wasn't I
didn't have options like Lola growing up
yeah so anyway Lola makes your month a
little bit easier the subscription is
fully customizable you can choose your
mix of products the absorbency the
number of boxes and the frequency of
delivery the subscription is super
flexible you can change skipper cancel
your subscription at any time so for 40%
off of all subscriptions visit my Lola
calm and enter our code b-tch when you
subscribe yeah it's 40% off don't miss
out on that go for it get it get that
okay bloody [ __ ] oh yeah but if you're
in like another country like if you're
in the UK or something that mean
different yeah No
I've actually experienced a lot of not
your level of backlash because I'm just
not as popular as you are especially in
the fitness space but the the fitness
community for some reason is very toxic
but it's the most I mean I guess because
I've been in like comedy space and I've
been in fitness I don't know the I don't
know gamer I don't know that other stuff
but the Fitness one is really toxic you
think because it's such a superficial so
and very sensitive yeah you know what's
crazy too on that note um I have a
friend who is just now going in shoes
she was in the beauty space and she
found a passion with fitness and she is
just now going into that Fitness world
and she just has always been open about
sharing her journey or personal journey
yeah and she's very much like find the
joy and fun and fitness and working out
and she that's what she loves to do is
coach people and like see them like
blossom and like yeah find their their
themselves basically through the workout
and she recently shared on her stories
the other way where she was talking
about eating pizza and like treating
yourself and she got so much hate like
flooded she came to me crying and she
was like oh I don't understand like like
I was just sharing like you couldn't
treat yourself and all these Fitness
people were like how dare you be into
this industry doesn't sound like you're
very fit I'm like I'm very healthy
that's good yeah wait that's crazy
that's projection you know is yeah
interesting because I have to walk this
super fine line because oh my gosh I
like pizza right if I show it it's a
good thing because it shows me shows
everybody posi body-positive it's that
you know don't feel guilt and honestly
like I did have orthorexia like back in
2012-2013 and to it is basically when
you're really obsessed with how healthy
your food is okay because I went off of
a bikini competition diet which was like
super high protein low fat just really
intense super restricted that by the
time I got off of it I was scared of
bananas and apples I was just like
tearing yeah cuz just a number that's
gonna add to your chaotic whatever yeah
and I had like metabolic like what do
you call it damage and you know anytime
I eat anything that wasn't like protein
powder and egg whites like a straight-up
became a sponge anyway so
took me years to like get out of that
and I struggled with it but like now I'm
not a healthy man do you made a video
about that right yeah well I made a lot
of it yeah stuff like that yeah I
stumbled across one because I was really
into like I got over I guess I guess
bulimia like in high school but I was
watching a lot of videos later just of
other people that went through it too
and I never I could never throw up but I
would just binge and then be in the gym
all day like just hours and hours and
hours and hours of like purging that way
right um but yeah I I just thought that
that video was was really cool of you
opening up and that was the first like I
don't know influence or video that I saw
people doing that Oh what was it like
okay I don't remember which video but I
there was one I think I titled like I
have an eating disorder I think disorder
and it's interesting because you don't
know that you have one until like yeah
the fact you're like whoa I was acting
crazy but back to the pizza thing it's
interesting because I wouldn't get that
type of flack people see me eating
pizzas like oh yeah she's being healthy
I mean she's like mentally she's being
healthy and then when I'm telling people
okay I'm gonna go like pretty much keto
this is why I'm gonna eat lots of
veggies and fats and like meats and
stuff all of a sudden it's like oh my
god you are so restricted this is so
unhealthy you haven't eaten this one but
you got the body positivity yeah because
they relate to you and her body shape
and they're like you're my goals because
you're not perfect
yes exactly now you're like improving
yourself and you're gonna start looking
like you're gonna have a six-pack and oh
no I don't know if I can't relate to you
anymore if you do any sort of improve
sounds like to me like cuz I don't know
really too much about this whole
situation but it sounds like because in
the past you were open about eating
disorders and then the other foods
ordered that you're talking about that's
probably the main reason why everyone is
like oh now you can't ever put
restrictions on your site ever again
because it just means that you have an
eating disorder so what are you supposed
to do now well I keep over-shared and
then I
yeah you know I put myself in this place
and I live a public life but I think
like geo said it's about education and
really I think what I need to somehow
show and I people aren't quite grasping
on yeah I decide you can have an eating
disorder and you can get better and then
you can continue healthy way yeah and I
think it's like yeah it's not like oh it
happens one time and you're damaged
forever type thing it's like no I I'm
now on like my um like a resurrection
yeah like that it's like a therapy yeah
heal the now you have the tools you need
like if you ever start slipping you're
like oh wait no like I know what that is
yeah is it wrong to think of an eating
disorder as like an addiction where
people say like oh if you've been an
addict in the past you're always gonna
be an addict like if you've been an
alcoholic you're kind of always an
alcoholic you're just always holding
yourself back from yeah I think that's
wrong separate from that I think it's
more like a relationship with food for
me personally that's it was like healing
that relationship because it stems from
psychological stuff rather than like I
feel like addicts it's like uh it's
almost no genetic I feel like sometimes
it runs like epically like yeah chemical
action whereas I felt like I'm not an
addict in any way but I got an eating
disorder because I like had a terrible
relationship with food and body image
yeah I think this is why Cassie is so
popular and like mega famous is because
if I was going if I was in the situation
that you are right now I'd just be like
this yeah I'd be like okay [ __ ] nut
subscribed yeah say that in a nice way
[Laughter]
successful sometimes I wish I could be
like you and just be like just come oh
wait like just get out so what's your
that sounds really maybe like understood
more like what's your wife or why you
want to I just wanna
okay I okay for me I had not been
blogging for a really long time so the
number one why was define who I was
again and writing for me is therapeutic
so why is a two blog everyday so that I
can be authentic again to myself
secondly I want to get in the best shape
of my life coz why not I just want to
and I she what do you mean I mean I want
to get down to 20% body fat which is
athlete levels okay with like fun
experiment yes and on my terms because
I've done it with a bodybuilding coach I
did a competition got like super eating
this order like hated myself every time
I looked in the mirror I was like I'm
still too fat I'm still too fat and I
was like literally 20 pounds louder
lighter than I am right now I want to do
it in my way where I am loving my body
loving every step of the way and
currently like I'm having so much fun
like I'm going out we're at the gym I'm
making up my own food and I'm not like
crazy or like I'm not hungry I think
people don't understand the hard work
excuse me the hard work that goes into
it and then how [ __ ] rewarding it is
to start seeing these muscles develop
because it's so hard to create and build
muscle like you guys it's [ __ ] hard
like like short girls it's you actually
forgot we don't produce that type of
testosterone to build that type of
muscles so anytime there's any sort of
like formation of like a like any sort
of muscle yeah it's addicting kind of
it's progress and I love progress yeah
whether it's in business or Fitness like
I love growth and young progress and
then thirdly it was for my mental health
so that goes back to the blogging like
it's just like I want discipline I want
focus I want a goal and I want to get
there yeah and and then it'll make me
more confident I think I'll just like be
better for my entire life you know yeah
I can really relate to your Third Point
because um ever since I had Tyco I kind
of put fitness on the back burner like
he hasn't been one of my priorities and
now that he's two and I've left the kind
of like level five priority of mine
doesn't really
I noticed mentally I'm not as like sharp
or on point or as driven as I once was
when I was incorporating so much more
fitness they just had constant goals
good goals yes and then just like my my
you know my chemical levels just felt
better like I had a better glow like
just everything about me when I was
training was just so much more on point
yeah and that's why I like working out
the morning because it sets the tone for
the day like you get the hardest thing
out of the way everything else is easy
peasy yeah and that's why to me it's
like addicting like healthy addicting
but it sets the tone that's my job
you know what when I listening to you
describe your second point and I'm like
why you want to go on this journey and
it's because you want to be the best
version of yourself I think a lot of
people misunderstand that obviously cuz
then for them they're like well what's
the point what's the goal right so if
you say I want to be the best version of
myself so in order to achieve that I'm
gonna climb a really high mountain like
that's a goal that they can understand
more I'm gonna do a triathlon where I'm
gonna like run 26 miles swim 25 miles I
don't know what a triathlon really is
but yeah so maybe this is something that
they don't understand and that's why
they're they're so quick to jump on well
then you have some mental issues because
there's no goal like they don't
understand your goal do you know what I
mean yeah it's also I think cuz maybe
because you attach to numbers - yeah
talking about that before and I know
like getting over eating disorder one
thing that you're obsessed about when
you're when you have an eating disorder
are numbers yeah yeah like everyday
jumping on the scale if that number
switches from like a decimal point
that's ruins your day yeah and then like
with food like if you went to calories
over like what you wanted to eat it
ruins your mental state and so maybe if
she does have a lot of people that were
recovering from eating disorders even
the figure of numbers yeah it like for
me it was a huge trigger and I didn't
weigh myself for a long-ass time that's
that's the same thing you can do yeah
yeah and then recently this year I
started doing it again because you know
what I was like I'm gonna conquer my
fear yeah oh that's yeah for you any
this is the best year I've ever had a
body in my life
and I'm nowhere near my go away or like
what I used to be I'm like 15 pounds
over what I was at my skinniest but I
was so unhappy then right um but I did
notice that like accepting what I
decided to do was accept the number
whatever it was and from there I could
just work and like celebrate progress
yeah but not like get mad at myself if
it wasn't what I wanted it to be so I'd
actually didn't set a goal number but I
just wanted to track yeah like if I walk
every day for 10000 steps does it make a
difference yeah and I just wanted to see
out of curiosity it's an experiment it
was a different mindset than when I had
an eating disorder but like having that
in that fear of numbers was yeah thing
so I'm thinking that maybe if you have
people that relate to you on that on
that front and then you attach that
number it maybe triggers them yeah
flipping again for sure it's a trigger
but first I want to say I'm so proud of
you for stepping on the scale because it
is scary it is yeah so scary I after
like my eating ordering and after my
eating disorder I didn't step on the
scale for like literally several years
yes like terrified of it but at the same
time I needed that I needed the space to
distance myself and be like the scale is
gonna define me like I'm much more than
my number but then you get to a point
where it's like okay I'm no longer
scared of it so why don't you face your
fear and step on it and then not be
emotionally attached to it so that was
like the second wave and so when I did
that and a lot of this came from my
husband Sam who was like why are you
scared of a number it's just a number
you guys are so so good
yeah like so smart stupid yeah I was
like okay so I just like stepped on and
I saw it and I was like okay and then we
were like it's just a data point it's
just a data point and like you said like
okay if I walk more I do a hit workout
vs Pilates workout like how does that
affect my number like as an experiment
and it's so empowering to be able to not
let the scale control you anymore well
and at the same time having enough
knowledge which this is I think would be
awesome for you to also I mean I'm sure
you've shared this with your fans
already but also sharing that like the
best way to gauge how you look is
literally just look in the mirror you've
literally just look in the mirror and
that'll tell you
than any skill can never tell you one to
it like your body composition changes so
drastically from one day to the next
yeah because now we're talking about
water intake we're talking about so like
how much sodium your body retains like I
can take the patient's yeah like I can I
can dehydrate myself for 24 hours and
you're gonna see some muscle definition
right and I'll take a picture in you
guys are gonna be like holy I can say
this is me after six months of working
out and you guys gonna be like wool I'm
gonna eat like maybe I don't know like
I'll eat like a high sodium steak for
example and then three hours later I'm
gonna look bloated as [ __ ] and I'm gonna
be like this is my before and I can fool
you guys dress yeah your body changes
yeah breezy yep but and we're gonna get
into that I was salivating actually can
help you with that it's a healthy habit
weight loss I love me too
I love it I think they have the right
attack approach yeah yeah just a little
less aggressive yeah with the mindset
going into it so they have physical goal
examples like better self-care
confidence in clothing more energy and
like your overall glow yeah the
psychological examples are like healthy
choices and your self-worth and better
mood it controls your anxiety and stress
but yeah
I that was like the mindset that I
really needed to yeah take on and then
the social examples is like go out to
avoid temptations at home self control
so social comfort trusting your ability
to make good choices and new just really
helped me like break some of those bad
habits I know we just discussed like the
fear of the scale and the fear of
numbers they actually help you to like
go on the scale and like not be afraid
and track your progress and celebrate
things and celebrate things that are
just even like social stuff that you
used to struggle with yeah so I really
like that numa's a habit changing
solution that helps users learn to
develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses it's based
in psychology so they teach you why you
do what you do and they give you tools
to break bad habits and replace them
with better ones I really like that they
like would take you through like a
little course each day yeah explain why
you're doing those things yeah and
you're never too busy for it because
they do offer 10-minute a day
so there's no excuses yeah and one of
the biggest and most accurate food
databases that lets you track meal
habits visualize portion sizes and see
calorie density at a glance so sign up
for your free trial today at noon that's
n oom calm slash b tch visit new comm
slash b tch to start your trial neucom
slash b tch so let's talk about your
because when you have goals and you're
seeing progress how that affects your
confidence because that made a huge
impact for me this year
that was unexpected I actually started
going on this really restrictive diet
cuz I found out I had SIBO which is I
thought it was cebu but that's in the
Philippines I am Filipino so maybe it's
both that's what it is but yeah I was
bloated for three years to the point
where I would wake up looking six months
pregnant no joke I have pictures like
it's crazy and that became like my new
normal but it was depressing cuz I'm
like I was working out like crazy I was
eating the right foods I was eating
super clean and nothing was working and
I was super under confident and it
started affecting my self-esteem a lot
and then I went to a gastroenterologist
found out I had C SIBO and I went on
this restrictive diet and it's funny the
mindset that people have when I'm like
oh I'm on this trip to diet and they
judge you right away they're like why
you don't have this way and I'm like no
you're about what can you eat or not eat
on so is on a low fodmap diet which is I
don't even know what the English like
freaked in I don't even want to begin to
try to pay that's fine like I understand
it but basically the list of what you
can eat was much shorter than the list
that you can't eat so I just went off
the list I could eat and I ate the same
thing every day and actually cleared it
so I tested for it I was positive I
don't answer microbials and am I gonna
hear you talk about anymore well
actually it's tough to be on it cuz I
can come back Buono on rebuilding my cup
but my point was I think I have never
worn a crop top in my life in my life
ever
and just the confidence of I
ended up losing 10 pounds on it which
was not my goal I was not like on a
weight-loss goal but I lost that and
then I lost 3 inches and my waist and I
was measuring like like doing like the
numbers yeah like see what it would
happen yeah and um I just felt like so
much more confident and I've been taking
like full-body pictures which I always
used to like avoid before I felt like I
was really hiding in my body and in my
clothes and after going through that
journey or Jews a journey and tracking
it all I I just feel so much more
confident I love my body but it started
with the self-acceptance oh yes you know
that's a start but yeah I don't know I
don't know where I'm going with that
that confidence level I don't think
people understand that when you have a
goal and you're just seeing progress it
boosts that mm-hmm
regardless of it's a number or not
because it's achieving something it's
checking something off and it's not just
about your body like you said it's a
great side benefit but you're trying to
solve a problem and you did it and that
feels so good
yeah bloating especially was struggling
if you're struggling for years and you
don't know what the hell is wrong with
your body and I don't know I mean my
body my enemy because I was like I can't
figure you out you know I check every
diet I got every like you know fitness
course I spend so much money and like
watch so many videos and could not
figure it out and then when you finally
get to see like oh the this problem this
goal is good yeah yeah I just like
increases your happiness yeah I'm really
happy with the way things are right now
like I'm happy that I go to like Nike
comm and I'm trying to buy some leggings
and it's like you look amazing
oh thank you yeah come from because
you're a mom and you you had a baby and
your body went like this like oh thank
you you look well
this is a thing that I'll kind of tap
into those kind of going into thinking
yeah um yeah so when I'm like on Nike
comet are my leggings or whatever and I
see girls of different body shapes I'm
like holy [ __ ] what a time to be alive
like that's yeah [ __ ] amazing cuz in
the past at least it was looked down
upon
right like to not look like these girls
that are constantly being advertised
it's like well then you're wrong you're
different and now we have a lot of
females that are like this is cellulite
I got it you got it - don't hide it and
we're all like yeah like that's okay and
it because it was you know we're in that
space right now when I got pregnant and
then I had my baby like I had gained and
I kept like ten extra pounds that I just
wasn't used to and keep in mind I had
been training really hard I want to stay
for like close to maybe seven years
where I was really dedicated and going
to the gym all the time and like really
tracking you know my nutrition yeah my
macros and my nutrition and stuff so my
initial reaction was like I gotta get
back I got to get back to my body I got
to get back to my body but then I'm like
why like why am I so worried about my
body at this point like why do I care
about my body and I realized that it was
because of these like societal pressures
and just how I was raised and just what
I was raised and what I was taught that
this is what beauty is women are
supposed to look this way you're
supposed to wear makeup you're supposed
to do whatever on that I really had to
take a step back and that's why I
appreciate like all of you girls here
and what you're doing Cassie um that
it's that it that that's not the point
like the point is not to look a certain
way for others the point is there's a
goal in mind and now what can we do to
set this that to achieve this goal so
for me what I had to change was that
mindset and the new goal became I'm
gonna provide for my child which was you
know I'm gonna eat right because I'm
breastfeeding at the time and then and
then I was going but if I'm gonna like
if I'm gonna dye it and do all that like
my kids not getting the nutrition
because I'm just focusing on the
physical part so that was really really
cool to like have those things kind of
click in my mind because I no longer
felt this pressure to look a type of way
yeah it was like no my goal right now is
to be like you know like the the giving
tree' for my kid you know and then once
he was fine and all of that then I'm
like cool what's my goal now okay well
my goal is I don't want a huff and puff
when I like go up some stairs right now
like I was literally like so out of
shape I just would go upstairs like 10
10 steps and I'm like breathing really
heavy yeah that's kind of changed I
think I got to work on my cardio but it
was everyone else yeah it was never one
of those like I want to look tiny and I
want to do this it was it was never that
I think sometimes people think that if
you have a goal that means you're not
happy with where you are now absolutely
and I don't
I don't think that's necessarily the
case like with everybody maybe for some
people but I think in your case like
you're like no I like I have I'm happy
now but I'm also like on a journey you
know what I think is interesting because
some of the comments and criticisms I
started getting were like oh you
shouldn't be worried about your weight
or your body fat and less like it's life
threatening and I felt like that was a
really extreme thing to say because you
wouldn't say that about career or
financials like oh you shouldn't worry
about how much you make unless you're
about to be homeless like it doesn't
make sense like yeah people is something
that fat people are healthy and skinny
people are not which is also wrong I
mean the whole thing it's just like yeah
you know what
everything is so personal everything is
your own thing like only you and maybe
your doctor knows what's going on so
it's not okay to like start diagnosing
people based on what you see on the
outside because there are people who are
skinny fat and they might look really
slim but you don't gonna like any fat
right now you don't look you know really
fat at all but in terms of my muscle to
fat like what you're used to
yeah my muscle to fat ratio is not what
I wanted to be yeah do you have like a
do you have like a goal in mind or
whatever I do know yeah you're just like
living life yeah and see there's seasons
right oh yeah seasons when you're like
you're cool and then a season two like
hey let's kick it up into high gear
exactly yeah yeah and like your body is
is like this really dope like temple if
you will where you can mold it and
change it and like it's [ __ ] cool
like that's why I got boob implants cuz
that's one thing I couldn't inch I
couldn't change and that was something
that I wanted to do for myself not
because I have like low self-esteem
which was one of the first things that
they always tell me I get breast
augmentation in or any type of surgery
it's like she must be insecure but it
was like man that's the only thing I
can't really grow I can get I asked I
can slim down my waist I can do all
these different things I could put fake
eyelashes on I can change my hair I
could literally change everything on my
body let me accept I guess my eye color
or maybe you can contacts butt boobs I
couldn't you know like I couldn't do
that so I'm like dude this is my ideal
type and this is the art piece that I
said oh yeah I'm this canvas that I'm
gonna paint my own picture that I love
that I love that way your body oh yes
yes what kind of cuz you're not well you
are in the fitness space
but you're also in comedy and stuff what
what did you get any backlash when you
got boob implants um yeah of course but
I don't think I I don't know how much
cuz I didn't really pay attention that's
good yeah and I guess it wasn't enough
for it to like leak into my like my
personal bubble space I guess it wasn't
much okay that's cool I think cuz I also
come off as like [ __ ] off yeah like
she's a [ __ ] anyway everyone's an
expert like when your own personal thing
a girl especially everyone says expert
like if you squat something they're like
actually your knees shouldn't be passed
right have you lift it's even worth in
the nutrition space like that straight
up is like religion and cults like
straight up and I went through some
drama with that sort of stuff too
there's so much like conflicting
information over that like what's
healthy for one person might not work
for another person that's the thing
people don't understand that they think
someone looks so good she's selling this
meal plan that's gotta be the oh yeah
it's like yes you'd like our DNA is
different our genes are different like
literally layers plastic surgery now I'm
not even telling the truth seriously and
just because you have a big butt all of
a sudden you can sell a bunch of like
booty programs dates like but that is
how it works because Instagram is like a
billboard and like why so much to talk
about in that phase that's how it's
always been to like you look like back
in the fit you know fifties with the
cigarette sells and like the women with
the like lungs anyone's it's all about
like what people perceive is like oh if
I get that then I'll look like her yes
yes and it's it's just so silly um
there's also like we all have different
blood types like people everything you
process food differently I remember back
like a couple years ago I was I do Blake
plant-based cooking uh-huh my youtube
channel and I'm personally I'm
pescetarian but at that time I was
transitioning from being like omnivore
eating all yeah meat and everything at
to like trying out a plant-based diet
okay and then like a year into it is
when I started having the like bloating
problem interesting and people were like
it's cuz you need to go back to eating
meat and I'm like I don't think it's
that yeah might be but I don't know and
yet though I was testing like that's
when I started incorporating fish back
into my diet yeah doing that it didn't
how
like there's something wrong but yeah so
many people are experts and so many are
like it's because of this it's because
you're not doing enough hit workouts
it's because you're not doing cardio
yeah because you don't know water and
I'm I don't know don't are you what do
you what if we hear all these comments
but then flip our perspective and then
hear them in a way where they love you a
lot
yeah I mean I comes from a place of
where they want to help me they're
connecting so hard that they're likely
we don't know how to show love other
than to criticize you because that's our
version of love yeah then for us to like
flip that in our head and be like oh
[ __ ] they really [ __ ] care about us
like what can I do to help them then cuz
they're obviously misinformed I hide you
presented the comments that are coming
in there's straight-up like novels it's
not just a one-liner or like like oh
you're you have an unique story it's
straight up like looks like this done
did it like every single comment so I
agree that it is coming from a place of
concern and love so how would you guys
suggest that I deal with it how I think
for me then it's it's what I kind of
suggested earlier where you kind of walk
them through you know just kind of the
fitness world as like basic as possible
like where people can grasp it because I
feel like the masses doesn't understand
like they're still stuck in like the the
misinformed like ten year ago fitness
like Fitness has completely progress and
skyrocketed within the last light I want
to see five years yeah yeah like once we
opened up barbell like things were still
kind of old school huh but then within
the last pipe pipe last five years like
the information is amazing like we found
out the food pyramid is a [ __ ] joke
yeah but like you grew up knowing as
facts that like it like this it is I
mean like eating fats is in now maybe it
won't be next year like I mean like
we're putting butter in their coffee but
they're finding out like all the low fat
stuff from the 90s actually has this
like additive in it yeah
[ __ ] and you're just sugar and stuff
health is a huge in that we're just now
like kind of finding out about you know
and I think it's great we have all this
information but you've got experiment on
yourself yes and like that's what I'm
doing so like on Monday I'm actually
going in to get some blood work done and
check out like my genetics and how it
affects my workouts gonna see my food
sensitivities like actually really
excited but I see percent I hate needles
oh yeah yeah I'm gonna be doing five
tests they need five vials of blood so
I'm like really scared but I'm also so
excited to see like okay let me just see
this whole in front of me what do I look
like inside and what can I do with that
because right now it's kind of just
experimentation yeah thing like oh if I
eat dairy it makes my face have pimples
but like why you know like yeah I'm
really excited to see that and your vlog
I mean your blogging all of that I'm
blogging all of it yeah I think that's a
great approach cuz you're like taking
them from ground zero and then you're
just building with them yeah and I think
what scares a lot of people too is that
you just don't see people or at least
people on like a big platform sharing
like literally how much they weigh what
their measurements are exactly what
they're eating and I'm just doing that
and it's like too raw I think yeah but
I'm just gonna keep going for it because
for me it's therapeutic and it for me
it's like I'm figuring out what I'm
learning and you're learning with me
good for you they're like your
appearance right now I say anything else
I do want to talk about boobs my boobs
again
no okay y'all know uh if you follow me
at all this is geo talking if you follow
me at all you know that I've been reppin
this like bra company ever since I was
personally introduced to it and that's
third love I absolutely have you third
have you heard of third love yes of
course
oh my god do you have another bras I
don't actually yeah you got to use this
coat
but what I really love about third love
is I have like irregular boobs I mean
all of us have interesting boobs like
there's new have a weird boom-boom girl
yeah so I didn't even know that I had no
idea that there were different types of
boob shapes and sizes and and all that
stuff so that you when you go into third
love you go and you take this 30 second
test and in this test to show you all
the different types of boobs and the
like okay well what do you what are your
boobs like and I'm like or look like and
then you click on it and then it says oh
okay what are some problem areas and
then after 30 seconds they recommend a
bra and I was super skeptical I'm like
yeah right like I'm doing this all at
home and there's not a person like
measuring yeah whatever bro
and then I did it they recommended it I
got it and it was shipped super freakin
fast to my house and it was perfect it
was such a perfect fitted bra like I
wasn't spilling out from it there wasn't
that cup gap yeah gaps fall off yeah and
I had the the issue where the straps dug
into my shoulders uh-huh none of I was
so like I preach it because I'm about it
yeah I've seen our weird boobs like up
in person with a third LeBron they're
weird no no yes wait can I just ask
what's weird about your boobs because
Paige I think it's like I was told from
my doctor like it's kind of instead of
it being this way like it's kind of
small like it drops I guess okay uh-huh
this is so your ribcage is weird not
your boobs yeah what makes me a weird
ribcage okay so for you guys and for
cast yeah go 2/3 love.com slash b tch
now to find your perfect fitting bras
and you can throw away all those other
balls I don't work you get 15% off your
first purchase so again that's third
love.com slash b TCH 15% off I'm about
it I'm about good fitting bras man that
sets the tone for your Hey
I hated wearing brawls cuz like okay I'm
over it I'm out um I'm not wearing a bra
okay nice you got weird
no but when I do wear a bra it is a
third love bra and I really [ __ ] love
that rough oh you got to try it no
that's over but I just really like I
really freaking love it though oh no I
think what you're doing is amazing I say
stick to it like stick to your guns cuz
that's the truest form of you ever and
if you're happy putting out like if
you're happy doing it yeah you'll get
the backlash but it's cuz it's change
you know like it's a huge change yeah
people are kind of like your parents
said I want you understand the space
that you're going into so you kind of
have to like hold their hand a little
bit and educate yeah it's just about
education and understandings yeah I
don't stop it like I think I think you
going through it you're gonna be the
happiest oh you're gonna produce the
best [ __ ] and I think whenever you're
like becoming your most authentic self
we're tuning back into that yeah there's
always gonna be some backlash or some
like like obstacles or whatever you know
because I think people want you to be a
perfect person or their version of what
a perfect person is and like you were
saying before how you kind of felt
vanilla because you were just kind of
catering to what I grew that you thought
everyone wanted to see so just you
getting back in tune with like you know
what I'm gonna be like the most mother
[ __ ] and authentic version is like kind
of pissing people off cuz you're just
not used to it and like I think I've
changed but actually I just haven't been
showing everything yeah for a long time
so I just feel so alive right now you
guys yeah yeah it's like I am like so
happy and motivated right now it feels
so good you just show up you should
flash your boobs right now your armpit
hair
I think just being unapologetic about it
like just like this is me this is me and
I'm not like offending anyone or hurting
any way and like you need to check
yourself
there's too much self love there's no
reason for anyone not to like you so I
think just with time as this kind of you
know brushes over or whatever and the
more honest you are and the more you
talk about like or at least talk about
how you something you disorder and how
it's not affecting you right now and
right I think just full honesty like to
say more stuff than you ever wanted to
say yeah and then over time everyone's
gonna be like oh actually she is healthy
she's not going back to her eating
disorder right you know all of that
stuff is gonna it's just all gonna blow
over and the more you can be yourself
the better it's gonna be and I'm really
excited that now you get to feel that
again because I'm sure you started that
way and you were so excited to be
yourselves and then you're hiding and
now you're like a rebirth and it is
beautiful I think it's gonna catalyst
for you okay well to be completely
honest always always honest yeah Oh a
[ __ ] ever so like I I stepped on the
scale and I was like oh my god I gained
like 14 pounds in a year which is a lot
for me and I was like what happened cuz
I started feeling like not as like
energetic not as like killing it in my
workouts as I let me just see what's
going on I was like woah okay like let's
like get this back into a place that I'm
happy with and that's how it started I
think that because I said that people
were like whoa like the scale is
controlling her she has an eating
disorder because of that but like for
real like I said I'm skin was like whoa
like okay it confirms how I feel so
there we go yeah that's the catalyst and
then I look you know what let's make
this a thing let's turn it into me
blogging again and just became like I
don't know like this amazing journey
that's been like three weeks now and I
feel so good I'm just like so happy and
you know what so what if it started with
me stepping on a scale yeah it's
interesting because I read this out of
digital it didn't start it started with
you not feeling good yeah well it's
argued well and even before that
actually before I stuff in the scale I
had this epiphany that I was no longer
being myself and being authentic yeah so
it was me really digging in deep and
like really being like who are you right
now and it was also me stepping like it
was everything all at ones like mental
physical spiritual so yeah but anyway I
remember when
cuz right when I started this journey
all of a sudden I was like on BuzzFeed
Daily Mail women's hell yeah I think
about it I was like dude I just want to
like get to live my life I just want to
lose a little body fat and all of a
sudden it's like news and like that's
weird but okay there's no bad Publio
doing you favors it's so many people
found out about you I can't believe you
even care um so anyway like right
underneath my article in women's health
there was a men's health article and it
was like celebrating some guy that like
loss of literally I don't forget what my
title was but it was something like oh
fitness blogger decides to lose weight
and it's like a controversy something
like crazy right like and people have
feelings and then you click on his and
it's like this whole journey started
with this guy stepping on a scale and
I'm like literally it's like the same
thing but I'm and there's like problems
because I haven't need a story and for
him it was like oh I he he says
something along lines of like I felt
like a potato or whatever any was like
fine for me it's not you're not allowed
to I'm denying it like I just have
people eat pictures and vegetable yeah I
feel like an eggplant could say potato I
think to that like like you said gaining
15 pounds in a year is a lot for you
like me so the first time I stepped on
the scale I didn't want to even at the
doctor's office yes the gynecologist and
I had gained 15 pounds too and she was
like that's not healthy like she told me
and I was like well you know what I like
maybe it's just an off day like a moment
me like she's like what's been going on
like you last year you came in and this
was your weight and now it's this and
like before that you had gained 5 pounds
I gained 20 pounds okay started with her
yeah I have like a I'm 5'4 I have like a
smaller frame yeah so that is a lot for
me and especially when I went years
hovering around the city huh and I was
like I don't know like I had no answers
I was eating the same way I was
exercising the same way but she really
was like you need to find out what is
wrong because there you go baby
problem
and some I mean for people to just
quickly be like this scale is
controlling you I mean you know your
body and there if there's a problem or
if that's not normal then that's not
normal and so you looking into it
shouldn't be judged by the masses like
them you know saying that you you know
you're getting controlled by your eating
disorder again like you just never know
what's going on you know it's personal
life yeah yeah and for me I know it was
a lot of like stress with like business
stuff and these are just like taking a
toll on me and I wasn't paying enough
attention to my stress hormone when
order is a [ __ ] and it's a [ __ ] to
women especially yeah [ __ ] you cortisol
but I was getting my brain scanned
because I wanted to if you have one come
at me know you and I like have a
relationship where like we roast each
other it's like it's love beautiful
brain I know I don't they're like you
don't have anything in there I was
trying to make sure that I was
maximizing my brain right so one thing
that he was saying not about my brain he
said I was fine he said I was in fact I
was [ __ ] really smart which I didn't
fight ok he did your to Zebari
didn't say that they don't measure that
in that you want to talk now when it's a
roasting I'm just kidding
I know so but one of the things he was
saying was like contrary to popular
belief that so this is a weird thing
that happened in Fitness where they're
like okay you should stop eating carbs
after six o'clock or they get they had a
set time yeah and then they were like
that's [ __ ] ridiculous there's no
such thing as that but then this doctor
now in 2019 was like well actually for
women there's this whole thing about
hormone growth in the middle of your
[ __ ] sleep cycle and some [ __ ] and
he's like you're supposed to stop eating
three hours before you go to sleep
because that's when the growth hormone
is like you know in full effect and
that's when you're like your body's
getting restored in blah blah blah he's
like the first thing you should do is
work out at least 30 minutes in the
morning so that you can burn off that
excess cortisol because if you don't the
rest of the day you just feel
hence and you're just stressed hmm and
that's where you gain like the the most
of your fat from that like the cortisol
levels he was like workout empty stomach
so at least 30 minutes and even just
going on a walk because I used to not
count walks as exercise goes like a
cardio walk yeah but like actually made
a huge difference yes going on a walk in
the morning and intermittent fasting
which is pretty much like it lands up
with that yeah you don't eat for 16
hours and then yeah you eat all your
food within eight hours yeah it lets
your body digest - I had a doctor tell
me because I wasn't like sleeping a lot
like years ago and I had like all these
like good issues and stuff she told me
that cortisol is directly related to
lower belly fat because I had noticed I
was saying my lower back I was starting
to like you know increase a little bit
it was that and once I started like
sleeping more and like thing taking care
of myself I started going away yeah so
it's super related it's insane yes
that's why all those yoga [ __ ] have
really like okay you know like I've met
some yoga people that like some of like
the craziest people I've ever met yeah I
mean not everybody but like a guy in LA
LA or maybe a whole nother level I think
there's just fanatics and everything and
yeah you have your vegans that are
fanatics yeah then you have your cool
vegans and then you have your Yogi's
that are really [ __ ] up and then you
have to show people like they just have
people that are like yeah feels like the
prey but then then people are like yeah
yeah there's extremes in everything yeah
yeah how you feel after this though do
you feel like you feel like yes I'm
sticking to it I'm making the right
decision I mean I knew from the
beginning this is the right decision
yeah we're gonna sway from my 90 days
like I'm doing it whether you want to
follow or not I'm still doing yeah yeah
following you girl they're not I think
you were like is she gonna make it
mater's are gonna follow the journey
just so they can like hopefully they act
all right so or some and you know what
at the end whether or not I make these
numerical goals I went through the 90
days in a self has made me stronger
already three weeks into it mentally
stronger so many per minute happy and so
I'm just excited to see what happens in
November I think is the
Yeah right before Thanksgiving right
before the holidays you guys better make
sure if you're not following Cassie
already
go tell him Jess all of her socials and
stuff in the description box and follow
her journey Blogilates second in
November and see what happened yeah so
hurt your videos are just great like
they're just so relatable and like I
feel like anyone fitness or not fit was
good I don't like it I don't like it for
you much no she put together this event
with Nick's cuz she had her own like
Nicks is that what it's called medic
line Oh wet wet and wild wouldn't while
the vent just cut out
I don't know this cut out I don't know
can you guys hear me I can hear you okay
okay sorry okay well it could up um yeah
so she was she put together this event
we all went there and she was just like
like training us don't just ignore the
pink guy yeah and she was like she was
like walking us through the work alright
she's like okay now we're gonna do I
don't know what you call it but you try
to make it sound pleasant and it's not
smiling and she looks so cute and well
together and presentable and she's like
doing these [ __ ] acrobatic type of
movements and I'm dying and I'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on I'm never
gonna hang out with Cassie ever again I
said you couldn't even go up your own
stairs to be so happy that's like my
goal is a challenge yeah but I need to
go to barbell you need to like kick my
butt oh yeah why probably won't kick
your butt Barto kick you okay bye
computer oh yeah I'm excited for that we
don't do anything that would be like
murdering you want to take yeah I want
to be so sorry like can't even move yeah
what types of exercises are you doing on
this journey
everybody okay so I love class pass like
I every night I pick a new class to go
to
I'm loving like circuit training hit
classes and in weightlifting there's one
powerlifting class at 8 so I'm doing
like deadlift hell yeah
stuff not as heavy as you but you know
I'm on my way you're probably really
heavy and I mean I don't I don't lift
anymore well I saw your video that was
like intense it was really intense yeah
and I'm doing like more running I'm
doing Pilates I'm dancing where that was
the other thing on my journey I wanted
to do things that made me really happy
and for some reason I just stopped
dancing so I started dancing again and
I'm just like it just makes me smile
like I just love it so Bennett dancing
do you do I say breakdancing please okay
oh my god
it's pop hip-hop okay Cory all right but
like like little fact back in high
school I wanted so bad to be a b-girl
lessons from a b-boy yeah I tried to
like be cool but I just like so didn't
look cool how far did you get did you
get the pose down we tried I'm I
specifically I wanted to be a pop and
Locker oh yeah no I can moonwalk though
not carpet he was trying to teach you
how to moonwalk on my knees and that was
like next night yeah do you know you can
moonwalk on your knees oh yeah you
shouldn't be able to so that's as far as
I have you ever tried pole dancing I
have that like it bruises my inner
thighs yeah yeah so yeah I'm also taking
these super intense stretching classes
you guys
I like this Russian medallist yeah and
straight up they like sit on you in your
Cola it's like and you want to die but
afterwards you just like feel so bendy
and open like I love it oh you really
want to get murdered oh yeah no murder
this is can people find you and like all
this journey name um people can find all
of my blogs on Blogilates comm and if
you're interested in starting any type
of like free workout calendar or
something I have like a beginner's
workout calendar a 28-day challenge a
30-day but plan whatever on my blog it's
all free and everything's on youtube.com
slash bah gratis reah yeah yeah
and then thanks again to our sponsors
Lola Noom and third love get the new
cleansing wipes or any of their 100%
organic cotton products for 40% off all
subscriptions visit my Lola comm and
enter b-tch when you subscribe new Maz a
habit changing solution that helps users
learn to develop a new relationship with
food through personalized courses for
your trial sign up today
new men oom calm slash b tch and third
love knows there's a perfect bra for
everyone so right now they're offering a
lizard listeners 15% off your first
order go to third love calm slash b tch
to find your perfect fitting bra and
check out our hey [ __ ] highlights
channel on YouTube now okay links in the
description and if you haven't yet will
you leave us five stars on itunes
perfectly we have too many bulimia here
have the table please like guys all
right guys yeah thank you so much thank
you Cathy so fun bye [ __ ]
bye bye